wall street zentralbanken und private
investoren haben eines gemeinsam sie
haben ein wachsendes interesse an crypto
währungen laut kein scherz erreichten
die investitionen in crypto fonds und
produkte im ersten quartal dieses jahres
einen rekordwert von 4,5 milliarden
dollar das vermögen in den usa beträgt
140 billionen dollar weltweit sogar 400
ein halbes prozent des globalen
vermögens ist in crypto währungen
angelegt bis zum ende des jahres werden
wir wohl einen prozent erreicht haben
bitcoin bekommt die meiste
aufmerksamkeit und tanz einen crypto
kollegen doch kritiker haben bedenken in
hinsicht der struktur und ihrer
volatilität im wesentlichen haben wir
nur ein weiteres tauschmittel erschaffen
das irgendwo in einem computer existiert
es hat keinen echten wert kann nutzen
liefert keine brauchbaren dienste es ist
eine blase es ist die zugrundeliegende
technologie einerblock chain die das
interesse der investoren wächst laut sie
die insights haben start ups die sich
auf blockt konzentrieren allein im
ersten quartal dieses jahres rund 2,5
milliarden dollar eingesammelt das ist
mehr als im gesamten jahr 2020 in
wirklichkeit sehen wir hier den aufbau
einer infrastruktur auf der tatsächlich
transaktionen durchgeführt werden können
auch die zentralbanken spüren den druck
eigene digital währungen zu schaffen
eine kürzlich durchgeführte umfrage der
banken ergab dass 86 prozent der
zentralbanken derzeit daran arbeiten
2017 waren es noch 65 prozent an
diesem punkt frage ich mich ob bitkom
nicht teilweise als eine art finanz war
für chinas gegen die usa angesehen
werden sollte es bedroht nicht nur dass
fiat geld s&p droht vor allem den us
dollar
doch wie denkt europa über crypto
währungen
die digitalisierung ist mittlerweile in
allen bereichen unseres lebens spürbar
und hat bereits die art und weise wie
wir bezahlen verändert ein digitaler
euro wäre ein symbol für den fortschritt
in europa und die europäische
integration
er würde als geld in elektronischer form
vom eurosystem der ezb und den
nationalen zentralbanken des euroraums
ausgegeben und könnte gleichermaßen von
privatpersonen und unternehmen verwendet
werden das bargeld wurde durch ihn nicht
ersetzt sondern ergänzt
[Musik]
wenn
wer weiß wie die zukunft der banken
aussehen wird einer der es vielleicht
wissen könnte ist rahmen er war bis 2011
staatssekretär im ministerium für handel
und industrie und leitet nun die
zentralbank eines landes das als eines
der intelligentesten und
fortschrittlichsten finanzzentren der
welt gilt singapore
rawi männern vielen dank dass sie sich
heute zeit genommen haben fr wie vor
nicht allzu langer zeit hielten sich die
zentralbanken von digitalen währung
komplett fern aber die lage hat sich
verändert ich meine wir haben länder wie
schweden die bahamas und china die
darüber reden möglicherweise ihre eigene
digitale währung in umlauf zu bringen
wie sollten zentralbanken in sachen
digitale währung in zukunft involviert
sein
ich denke wir sollten hier unbedingt
involviert sein das heißt wir müssen mit
der technologie schritt halten auch wenn
wir dabei am anfang viel lehrgeld
bezahlen durch das patenprojekt konnten
wir wertvolle erfahrungen sammeln wir
unsere digitale währung den
singapur-dollar auf einer block 10 in
umlauf gebracht haben ich denke es ist
wichtig sich mit dieser technologie
auseinanderzusetzen und sich nicht davor
zu verstecken
jasper oben war ein gemeinschaftsprojekt
des kanadischen blog chain netzwerks
corder und das quorum netzwerks in
singapur aus einer kooperation der
monetary authority of singapore und der
kanadischen zentralbank wurde 2016
untersucht ob es einfachere und
effizientere zahlungs und
abwicklungssysteme durch die ausgabe
digitaler türken mit hilfe der
zentralbanken geben kann in der ersten
phase wurde ein digitales token
äquivalent des singapur dollars
ausgegeben dieser beruhte auf einer
proof-of-concept basierenden imperium
boxing den als capcom bezeichneten
kanadischen digitalen dollar entwickelte
man um zu verstehen wie block chains in
realen zahlungsabwicklung szenarien
genutzt werden können phase 2 stand für
die einführung von software prototypen
für interbanken zahlungen hauptsächlich
war microsoft damit beauftragt diese
prototypen in ihrer blogs chain
bereitzustellen in der letzten phase
wurden möglichkeiten zur integration der
plattform und der digitalen assets unter
wahrung der privatsphäre der
marktteilnehmer untersucht buben war ein
voller erfolg so konnten die bank of
canada und die monetary authority of
singapore versuchsweise ein schnelleres
und kostengünstigeres
grenzüberschreitendes zahlungssystem
entwickeln
wir müssen unsere perspektive etwas
ändern und uns fragen zu welchem zweck
was soll eine digitale währung leisten
müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen einer
grenzüberschreitenden handels währung
und einer einzelhandels währung für
konsumenten bei einer digitalen
handelswährung würde es sich um genau
das handeln was wir als block 10 kennen
es kommt hier nicht auf jeden einzelnen
digitalen türken an aber in summe werden
mit ihrer hilfe die eigentlichen
transaktionen durchgeführt nach diesem
system würde zumindest singapur eine
digitale währung in umlauf bringen
kanada würde gern eine digitale währung
herausgeben um grenzüberschreitenden
zahlungsverkehr zu vereinfachen aber sie
kommen nicht so einfach aus ihrem
bankensystem heraus weil die leute immer
noch an traditioneller viert währung
festhalten wenn also ihr ansatz nur
grenzüberschreitende zahlungen sind
brauchen sie keine digitale
einzelhandels währung unterschiedliche
währungen spielen also in diesem
szenario keine rolle das heißt
zentralbanken geben digitale währungen
direkt an die öffentlichkeit raus und
wir sehen im moment keinen bedarf für
eine separate einzelhandels wären ein
digitaler euro würde also die effizienz
eines modernen zahlungsmittel bieten und
wäre gleichzeitig sicheres
zentralbankgeld es würde sich dort
anbieten wo menschen ungern mit bargeld
bezahlen der schutz der privatsphäre
sollte beim euro einen hohen stellenwert
haben so kann er dazu beitragen das
vertrauen in den heutigen
zahlungsverkehr aufrecht zu erhalten er
könnte den übergang der europäischen
wirtschaft in die digitalisierung
unterstützen und innovationen im massen
zahlungsverkehr aktiv fördern derzeit
prüfen die ezb und die nationalen
zentralbanken des euroraums welche
vorteile und risiken ein digitaler euro
hätte denn der anstieg von
vermögenswerten wie bitcoin ist größer
als die damalige südsee blase oder die
niederlande schuldenblase
[Musik]
nun wissen sie unser ansatz ist diese
art von vermögenswerten erst mal genau
zu prüfen für uns ist bitcoin keine
währung es ist für uns klar eine
wertanlage es ist ein vermögenswert dem
nur sehr wenig zu grunde liegt was zu
einer menge volatilität führt sehen sie
wenn man hier versucht herauszufinden
was der wirkliche wert des assets ist in
das man investiert hat stößt man schnell
auf schwierigkeiten und das ist genau
der punkt dass renditen dieser art von
crypto wertanlagen nicht mehr der
rendite anderer anlagen vergleichbar
sind deshalb müssen anleger die in
crypto vermögenswerte investiert haben
ihr portfolio so gut es geht streuen
meiner meinung nach macht es nicht viel
sinn hier zu investieren da man das
problem der starken volatilität hat vor
ein paar monaten hatten wir noch die
situation dass die preise durch die
decke geschossen und nun sehen sie ja wo
bestehen das macht das alles sehr
schwierig auf geübter schutz wenn sie
also schwierigkeiten haben
herauszufinden was die eigentliche basis
oder grundlage ihrer investition ist
dann denke ich haben sie keine wirkliche
investition getätigt sondern spekuliert
auch wenn es sich anders anfühlt diese
starken preisschwankungen zeigen dass es
nur wenig vertrauen zb in stable points
gibt
eine währung sollte somit keine anlage
für spekulationen seien oder in dieser
richtung anreize schaffen sondern ein
stabiles element unserer geldpolitik
darstellen
würde also ein digitaler euro nicht zu
denen crypto ersatzzellen rittersitz
unterscheiden sich grundlegend von
zentralbankgeld ihre preise unterliegen
häufig großen schwankungen so dass sie
nur schwer als konstantes zahlungsmittel
zu verwenden sind zudem steht hinter
ihnen meist keine vertrauenswürdige
institution
der zahlungsverkehr befindet sich im
umbruch und die zentralbanken spielen
dabei eine wichtige rolle grundlage des
europäischen zahlungsverkehrs muss ein
wettbewerbsfähiger und innovativer
zahlungs markt sein der die bedürfnisse
der verbraucher innen erfüllt und die
souveränität europas war
fachleute der ezb und der nationalen
zentralbanken des euroraums haben eine
reihe grundlegender anforderungen für
einen digitalen euro festgelegt
beispielsweise muss er leicht zugänglich
robust sicher und effizient sein
es gibt also eine menge punkte die bei
der einführung einer digitalen währung
zu beachten sind meint auch der
ehemalige ceo von goldman sachs martin
scharf ist ich kann leider noch nicht
sagen welche form genau die digital
währung einer zentralbank annehmen wird
es ist nicht mal zu 100 prozent klar ob
diese auf einer blog chain existieren
muss oder nicht sie muss auf jeden fall
weit verbreitet seien die privatsphäre
muss geschützt sein und es sollte eine
gewisse fehler toleranz geben wir sehen
hier auf diesem gebiet geopolitische
überlagerungen und dass einige staaten
wie zum beispiel china dieses thema sehr
aggressiv angehen und eine digitale
währung einführen ich weiß zwar nicht
wie die gespräche hinter verschlossenen
türen aussehen aber natürlich möchte man
den internationalen handel gerne in
dieser währung abwickeln als bisher in
dollar auf der anderen seite ist man
noch sehr skeptisch da vielleicht
überwachung eine große rolle spielt oder
sogar seine souveränität an die nutzung
der digitalen währung geknüpft ist der
schutz der privatsphäre die bekämpfung
von geldwäsche und die transparenz für
kunden das ist alles sehr sehr schwierig
im gleichgewicht zu bringen aber ich
möchte auf etwas anderes zurückkommen
dass ich vor zehn jahren den früheren
bitcoins prophezeit habe und ich denke
es hängt damit zusammen damals meinte
ich dass ich sehr zuversichtlich bin
dass die fed die digitalisierung des
us-dollars fortsetzen wird und eines
tages wird er ein digitales asset seien
quasi eine crypto währung es hieß das
würde nie passieren aber ich sagte sag
niemals nie und nun bin ich sicher dass
es in naher zukunft passieren wird es
gibt unterschiede in der denkweise von
leuten an ost- und westküste die art und
weise wie in silicon valley an sachen
herangegangen wird unterscheidet sich
doch sehr von dr org oder de aber
irgendwann wird es auch hier ein
umdenken geben
wir können die vorboten bereits sehen
wer die beratungen des kongresses in den
tiefen der pandemie genau verfolgt hat
wurde vielleicht an die früheren
konjunktur gesetze der federal reserve
bank erinnert einen digital us dollar zu
schaffen und diesen an die amerikaner zu
verteilen ich weiß noch wie ich dachte
das ist wirklich eine gute idee aber
es ist und bleibt ein wirklich
unglaublich riesiges projekt es gibt
sowohl für den groß- als auch für den
einzelhandel die möglichkeit das
zahlungssystem weiter zu modernisieren
und sie werden mit der digitalisierung
noch lange zu kämpfen haben bis ihr
bankkonto ein komplett digitales
konstrukt sein wird
die frage ist wollen wir dass es konto
basiert ist soll es genau so
funktionieren wie unsere papier dollar
scheine nur eben als digitaler token das
sind alles themen die im moment sehr
aktiv diskutiert werden ich erinnere
mich noch als der argentinische peso an
den dollar gekoppelt war das war
großartig man konnte pesos an
geldautomaten bekommen und das lag daran
dass die währungsbehörde beide währungen
dollars und pesos gleichermaßen
verfügbar machte und das ist jetzt die
herausforderung bei den stable konz
ich denke es ist eine absolute
notwendigkeit jetzt einen digitalen
dollar in umlauf zu bringen
amerika und die federal reserve sind
hier in zugzwang und nicht nur wieder so
eine übergangslösung nein ich denke es
ist unvermeidlich dass wir jetzt nägel
mit köpfen machen denn wenn wir etwas
aus der politikwissenschaft kennen ist
es souveränität einzuhalten ein
souveräner staat kann seine steuern nur
in der währung verlangen die er auch
ausgibt und das ist ja auch gerade das
was die zirkular i tät dieser währung
noch unterbindet
was wäre wenn der gesamte internationale
handel in höheren bezahlt und alles
reibungslos gegen den digitalen tyrann
getauscht werden könnte würden ihnen die
leute dann tatsächlich verwenden
vielleicht würde ich ein konto für
jahren eröffnen okay man müsste mich
erst einmal davon überzeugen dass meine
privatsphäre geschützt wird und nicht
einfach nur sagen dass es so ist es
müsste mathematisch kryptographisch
garantiert sein dass meine privatsphäre
gewahrt wird und ich bin mir vollkommen
sicher dass solche gespräche gerade
stattfinden
martin scharfes spricht hier einen
wichtigen punkt wie sieht es aus mit der
akzeptanz eines digitalen euro es wurden
bedenken geäußert dass zentralbanken
durch die einführung einer eigenen
digitalen währung in den besitz
sensibler informationen über die nutzer
innen gelangen könnten bei privat
imitierten zahlungs instrumenten wie zum
beispiel stable coins ist das risiko in
den besitz sensibler informationen zu
gelangen sehr groß die meisten nutzer
innen und investoren sind auch besorgt
das neu entstehende private
zahlungslösungen insbesondere wenn sie
unreguliert sind treiber risiken mit
sich bringen können im falle eines
digitalen euros könnten solche risiken
durch die beteiligung der zentralbank
gemildert werden eine globale
meinungsumfrage zum öffentlichen
vertrauen in monetäre institutionen
zahlungs merkmale und digitale währungen
zeigt die bedeutung des vertrauens in
die zugrundeliegenden systeme während
rund 79 prozent aller zahlungen im
euroraum immer noch bargeld
transaktionen sind sank der anteil
dieser transaktionen zwischen 2017 und
19 allein in den niederlanden von 41 auf
32 prozent
gerade junge europäerinnen machen laut
jüngsten ezb umfragen ausgiebig gebrauch
von bargeld bevorzugen aber
elektronische zahlungen und erwarten von
der entsprechenden infrastruktur dass
sie sicherheit und schnelligkeit
garantiert auch die corvette 19 krise
hat zu einer verschiebung der
zahlungsgewohnheiten hin zu kontaktlosen
zahlungen und ecommerce geführt diese
verlagerung hin zu kontaktlosen
zahlungen von statt obwohl banknoten im
vergleich zu anderen arten von
oberflächen mit denen menschen im
täglichen leben in kontakt kommen kein
besonders großes risiko einer corona
virusinfektion darstellen in der
pandemie beschleunigte sich das
innovationstempo und die bürger innen
zeigen eine zunehmende vorliebe für
digitale zahlungen vor diesem
hintergrund hat der ezb-rat im januar
2020 eine hochrangige task force
eingerichtet um die arbeit an digitalen
zentralbank währungen im euro raum
voranzutreiben
würde ein digitaler euro also von der
ezb zentral verwaltet werden ryan brooks
war lange zeit teil des bankensystems
und meint dezentralität ist der
schlüssel in meinem letzten job für die
regierung und leitung des bankensystems
haben wir versucht klarzumachen dass
weder fanatiker noch feinde von toto
währungen sind aber wir glauben dass die
märkte richtlinien und klarheit brauchen
ich sage nicht dass mehr oder weniger
kontrolle eine gute sache ist aber eine
reihe von regeln zu haben wäre für mich
gut vorstellbar stelle sich nur mal vor
straßen ohne tempolimit niemand weiß ob
man schnell oder langsam fahren soll das
wäre fahrlässig wir haben tempolimits an
die sich jeder halten kann und so etwas
brauchen wir auch bei crypto währungen
ich denke die anziehungskraft von crypto
liegt er in der dezentralisierung und
weniger in der fehlenden regulierung
denn hier liegt die wahre
herausforderung worum es hier wirklich
geht ist der aufbau des finanzsystems
abseits der zentralisierung leute die
denken wir versuchen geheimes magisches
internet geld zu erschaffen das nicht
überwacht werden kann sind
wahrscheinlich in der falschen branche
es geht um ein dezentrales finanzsystem
das nicht von bänkern kontrolliert wird
das wird der große vorteil der krypto
wirrungen sein und was es mit der
stabilität zumindest wenn man sich
andere märkte anschaut stabilität ist
oft mit zentralisierung verbunden oder
war zumindest eine folge davon
schließlich hatten die usa eine
dezentralisierte wirtschaft bis man sich
entschied eine fett zu gründen um eine
art von stabilität zu erzeugen
doch wenn wir hier ein system von regeln
wie zum beispiel
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen wollen
gleich das nicht schon fast einer
zentralisierung
wir haben die fehler im neunzehnten
jahrhundert nicht gegründet weil die
dezentralisierung schlecht war sondern
weil wir keine technologische
möglichkeit hatten den menschen zu
erlauben direkt miteinander zu handeln
und so musste jemand dollar in umlauf
bringen die überall akzeptiert werden
konnten aber jetzt haben wir eine
technologie die das für uns tun sehen
sie in der vergangenheit war die post
die einzige möglichkeit um informationen
auszutauschen es gab für jemanden in new
york eine möglichkeit nachrichten nach
san francisco zu übermitteln jetzt haben
wir email und brauchen die post nicht
mehr so verdrängen technologien manchmal
ganze institutionen die wir zuvor
aufgebaut haben also weiterhin nach
alter stabilität suchen würde ich sagen
ist diese sehr brüchig es war zwar
stabil aber es wurde alles streng
reguliert und kontrolliert
es war auch unglaublich teuer und hat
letztendlich nicht gut funktioniert es
war lediglich das beste was wir hatten
nun haben wir etwas besseres
die ezb ist die hüterin des euro ob es
sich um banknoten und münzen oder um
einen euro in digitaler form handelt
spielt dabei keine rolle unsere aufgabe
ist es den wert unserer gemeinsamen
währung zu erhalten unabhängig von
seiner form soll ein digitaler euro
letztendlich von der zuständigen
zentralbank geschützt und reguliert
werden ein wesentlicher teil der aufgabe
des euro systems besteht darin die
bürger innen mit risikolosen geld für
ihre zahlungen zu versorgen bargeld ist
zwar immer noch das vorherrschende
zahlungsmittel doch neue technologien
und die zunehmende nachfrage der
verbraucher innen nach unmittelbarkeit
verändern die art und weise wie die
europäischen bürger innen bezahlen dies
zeigt sich in der rasanten zunahme
elektronischer zahlungen
system es gibt einen guten grund dafür
dass der umlauf durch das bankensystem
reguliert wird weil banken nämlich aus
der monetären basis ihrer kreditvergaben
sozusagen in dem kredit
schöpfungsprozess geld erschaffen wenn
die zentralbanken nun direkt digitale
währungen an die allgemeinheit ausgeben
würden was würden dann die zentralbanken
mit diesem digitalen geld machen das
geld der zentralbanken ist nicht darauf
ausgerichtet leuten den kreditrahmen zu
vergrößern das ist die aufgabe der
banken wir müssen also darüber
nachdenken wie das in der praxis
funktionieren soll und man muss auch
fragen warum überhaupt warum sollen die
zentralbanken die digitalen währungen
ausgeben mal abgesehen von den
grenzüberschreitenden zahlungen für den
einzelhandel ich denke es ist vielmehr
eine geldpolitische frage als eine rein
politische
menschen haben das gefühl ein digitales
äquivalent zu bargeld zu brauchen dass
alle eigenschaften von bargeld hat also
anonymität und vollkommene akzeptanz um
nur die beiden wichtigsten zu nennen
wenn ich eine banküberweisung auf ihr
konto mache ist das allenfalls
vertraulich aber wenn die behörden den
verdacht haben dass etwas nicht stimmt
können sie die transaktion aufheben und
versuchen verfolgen wir ja geldwäsche
oder steuerhinterziehung und können
diese aufdecken denn es gibt immer eine
digitale spur die transaktions
aufzeichnungen wenn wir nun komplett auf
einen digitalen zahlungsverkehr
umsteigen verlieren die leute genau
diese absolute anonymität des bargelds
wenn ich ihnen einen koffer voller
bargeld gebe gibt es keine möglichkeit
das zurückzuverfolgen
warum braucht es dann überhaupt
zentralbankgeld beziehungsweise einen
digitalen euro für haushalte und firmen
in einer zunehmend verzahnten und vor
allem digitalisierten welt hängt der
zahlungsverkehr dem tempo der wirtschaft
oft noch hinterher
regulierungen sorgfaltspflichten und
unterschiedliche it-systeme zwischen
banken und währungsräumen können gerade
bei auslandsüberweisungen noch immer
tage dauern dass es nicht nur
ineffizient sondern erzeugt auch
zusätzliche kosten bitcoin oder
facebooks währung die im beabsichtigen
genau dieses problem zu beheben jedoch
nicht ganz ohne risiken für nutzer innen
dafür die stabilität der währung
schließlich keiner garantiert wie die
hohen preisschwankungen von bitcoin
deutlich machten ein digitaler euro als
wertanlage der in unbegrenztem umfang
verfügbar ist wäre daher auch nicht
zweckdienlich vorteile würden damit nur
indirekt entstehen wenn transaktionen
beispielsweise beim onlinekauf schneller
abgewickelt werden und firmen direkter
und transparenter überblick über
kontostände und transaktionen hätten die
immer wieder geäußerte angst die ezb
wurde damit den leuten das bargeld weg
nehmen bis daher haltlos die von der ezb
initiierte digitale revolution wäre also
für anleger innen und investorinnen
anfangs nicht spürbar
[Musik]
das bringt uns zuliebe wir hatten visa
mastercard die sich zurückzogen
die g7 staaten mahnten zur vorsicht wie
stehen sie dazu der facebook sagt dass
die regulierungsbehörden die regulierung
hinauszögern und das gleichbedeutend
damit ist innovation zu deckeln bzw zu
bremsen
wir begrüßen die innovationen ich denke
der ansatz von facebook hat eine enorme
menge an neuen ideen und eine neue art
zu denken hervorgebracht was meiner
meinung nach essenziell für die zukunft
ist und wie sie eben gesagt haben hat
das interesse der zentralbanken an
digitalen währungen durch das projekt
von facebook einen großen schub bekommen
die kernaussage von facebook ist dass es
grenzüberschreitende zahlungen billiger
schneller und besser machen will und es
will die finanzielle inklusion
verbessern weil es viel einfacher ist
ein facebook konto zu haben als ein
bankkonto auf den ersten blick sind dass
hochgesteckte ziele aber ich denke
zentralbanken und die banken
gemeinschaft müssen hier an antworten
für firmen wie facebook arbeiten denn so
etwas brauchen wir
das wurde in gewisser hinsicht etwas
verschlafen und wenn überhaupt nicht gut
umgesetzt ich will damit nicht sagen
dass facebooks ansatz schlecht ist aber
er zeigt hier eine echte lücke auf und
ich verstehe die idee dahinter
eine weitere nuance in der ganzen
problematik der zentralbank und der
digitalen währung ist die frage geht es
hier nur um zahlungen geht es hier nur
um anonymität ich denke der ganzen
widerstand hat auch mit der dominanz des
us-dollars zu tun dass eine gesunde
sache für die globale finanzstabilität
ist denn wenn zwei länder miteinander
handel treiben oder zwei menschen
transaktionen durchführen wird immer
auch ein teil des dollars umgerechnet
unsere wechselkurse die bilateralen
wechselkurse beziehen sich alle auf den
us dollar
eine gute oder schlechte sache das
system hat bis jetzt ziemlich gut
funktioniert
doch für die zukunft ist es nicht
unvernünftig zu fragen ob das noch der
beste weg ist hier weiter zu kommen oder
ob wir nicht ein stabileres system von
globalen reservewährungen finden sollten
es soll sich ja nicht wieder alles um
die vereinigten staaten drehen
aber es scheint dies wäre die denkweise
der regulatoren und zentralbanken wir
haben hier eine starke konzentration auf
den us dollar und das ist ein risiko was
ist wenn das schiefgeht wollen wir nicht
etwas das ein bisschen mehr
diversifiziert ist und ich denke das
sind die fragen mit der sich die
zentralbanken gemeinschaft
auseinandersetzen muss
bitcoin oder facebooks lepra haben viele
der zentralbanken zum nachdenken
gebracht
digitale zentralbank währungen auf der
blog chain sogenannte cds sind ein seit
2008 zehn intensiv diskutiertes thema
viele zentralbanken der welt diskutieren
bereits ihre einführung oder planen sie
konkret
wir werden also bald einen digitalen
euro haben
aber was bedeutet das überhaupt hinter
dem digitalen euro steht nämlich kein
konzern und auch keine geschäftsbank
sondern die europäische zentralbank und
das wichtigste ziel der ezb ist
preisstabilität
einfacher gesagt ein brot kostet mit dem
digitalen euro in zukunft noch genau so
viel wie jetzt mit der mastercard und
genau das ist seit dem aufkommen und der
immer höheren akzeptanz von crypto
währungen wie bitcoin und co nicht mehr
so einfach über diese zahlungsmittel vor
allem deren unberechenbare
wertsteigerungen beziehungsweise
verluste haben die zentralbanken keine
kontrolle die ezb möchte dem
entgegenwirken und stattdessen eine
stabile digitale währung als
weiterentwicklung des klassischen euro
einführen
das hieße dass wir neben den jetzigen
zahlungsmöglichkeiten bar oder per karte
eine dritte bekommen einen
elektronischen euro den wir über das
smartphone aber auch offline über eine
datenkarte nutzen können viele
finanzexperten halten das für längst
überfällig denn in den meisten
skandinavischen ländern kann kaum noch
mit bargeld gezahlt werden und darauf
muss die ezb reagieren derzeit prüft die
ezb unter welchen voraussetzungen dieses
digitale zentralbankgeld sicher
eingeführt werden könnte ezb chefin
lagarde betonte in einem bloomberg
exklusiv interview wiederholt wie
wichtig es sei die sicherheits einer
digitalen währung zu garantieren und das
vertrauen in diese zu stärken
ich lege jetzt mal meine eigene
überzeugung ab weil ich die präsidentin
der europäischen zentralbank bin
es gibt einen verwaltungsrat in dem alle
präsidenten der nationalen zentralbanken
sowie die mitglieder des direktoriums
vertreten sind und die entscheidung ob
wir einen digitalen euro einführen
werden oder nicht wird von diesem organ
also dem direktorium und dem rat der
zentralbanken getroffen mit und das wird
mitte des jahres 20 21 passieren wenn
wir die ersten ergebnisse vorliegen
dieser bericht wird eine analyse von
über 8.000 rückmeldung veröffentlichen
die wir im rahmen des beratungsprozesses
erhalten haben er wird dem europäischen
parlament vorgetragen einem der
hauptakteure sowie der kommission und
dem eu rat nicht zu vergessen der euro
gruppe
danach wird der ezb-rat auf grundlage
dieser beratung und unserer
vorangegangenen arbeit entscheiden ob
wir mit dem experiment digitaler euro
weiter machen
daraufhin wird es eine zweite
entscheidung geben wahrscheinlich in
einem jahr oder lassen sie es sechs
monate sein ob aufgrund dieser ersten
bewertung tatsächlich schon ein
digitaler euro eingeführt wird
aber lassen sie uns das realistisch
betrachten der ganze prozess wird meiner
meinung nach noch weitere vier jahre
dauern vielleicht noch etwas länger also
ich hoffe natürlich dass wir es
innerhalb von vier jahren schaffen aber
es bringt eine menge technischer aspekte
als auch grundlegende veränderungen mit
und wir müssen sicherstellen dass wenn
wir einen digitalen euro einführen wäre
es vernünftig machen das sind wir den
europäern schuldig für die europäer und
europäerinnen sollen sicher und
unbesorgt damit umgehen können sie
sollen wissen dass sie zentralbank
gesichertes geld erhalten ich würde
sagen es muss das äquivalent einer
digitalen banknote sein mit dem gleichen
maß an sicherheit und rückendeckung
durch die zentralbank es muss also
wirklich sicher und stabil sein
wir müssen außerdem sicherstellen dass
wir nicht unser bankensystem zerstören
sondern es verbessern
ich sage dass hier sehr deutlich da ich
weiß dass bestimmte finanzinstitute mit
denen wir zurzeit arbeiten sich auf uns
verlassen
einige banken schauen gerade ziemlich
besorgt auf diese entwicklung am
finanzmarkt aber das brauchen sie nicht
denn keine zentralbank wird zukünftig
als kundenmanager oder risiko bewährter
für die vergabe von kreditlinien
auftreten
diese finanzinstitute werden also
weiterhin koexistieren und ihre
geschäfte tätigen können bargeld wird
auch weiterhin verfügbar sein ebenso wie
digitale währung aber
man muss sich das auch anschauen wie
sich das verhalten der bürger innen
während der kogit 19 krise geändert hat
wie sie im internet einkaufen oder die
art und weise wie sie ihr essen
bestellen oder bezahlen
dies bewegt sich bereits in einer
digitalen dimension vor der wir keine
angst haben sollten und wie ich schon
sagte wir müssen den europäern und
europäerinnen einen sicheren stabilen
alternativen zahlungsweg an is muss
also weitere vier jahre entwicklungszeit
haben wir diese zeit noch um ein
durchdachtes und technisch ausgereiftes
digitales euro system einzuführen
die ausgabe eines digitalen euro wäre
für fast alle tätigkeiten des euro
systems von bedeutung und hätte
weitreichende auswirkungen auf die
gesamte gesellschaft
gleichzeitig sind aber auch experimente
zu den praktischen aspekten eines
digitalen euros notwendig um die stärken
und schwächen der verschiedenen optionen
zu untersuchen
wir haben gehört dass viele banken um
ihre existenz fürchten die einführung
eines digitalen euros könnte die
transmission der geldpolitik
beeinträchtigen und sich negativ auf die
finanzstabilität auswirken auch in
krisensituationen wenn die sparer
weniger vertrauen in den gesamten
bankensektor haben könnten liquide
mittel sehr schnell in den digitalen
euro umgeschichtet werden wenn also das
abheben von digitalem geld einfacher
wird als das abheben von bargeld könnte
es die wahrscheinlichkeit von schweren
bank runs erhöhen und die
finanzstabilität schwächen
diese beispiele machen deutlich dass die
ausgestaltung des digitalen euro
sorgfältig geprüft werden muss
es sollte vor allem überlegt werden ob
er für haushalte und unternehmen direkt
oder indirekt über banken zugänglich
sein sollte ob er vergütet und ob die
digitalen euro bestände einzelner nutzer
innen begrenzt oder unbegrenzt sein
sollten
[Musik]
für den moment halten wir uns die option
offen ob und wann dies geschehen soll
aufgabe der ezb ist es das vertrauen in
das geld zu sichern es muss
sichergestellt werden dass der euro für
das digitale zeitalter ist die
kommission der ezb hat einige szenarien
beschrieben die das euro system zur
ausgabe eines digitalen euro sparen
lassen könnte und auch anforderungen
aufgeführt die die neue geld form
erfüllen sollte
szenario 1 positive auswirkungen auf
innovation und autonomie der eurozone
unabhängigkeit und digitalisierung der
europäischen wirtschaft können von einer
digitalen form des zentralbank geldes
profitieren die den bürgern zur
verfügung gestellt wird die ausgabe
eines digitalen euros kann ein weg sein
die die digitalisierung der wirtschaft
zu fördern und die entwicklung
innovativer europäischer lösungen in
allen möglichen branchen zu unterstützen
in einem solchen szenario würde die
ausgabe eines digitalen euros dazu
beitragen die europäische autonomie im
bereich des massen zahlungsverkehrs zu
erhalten und könnte ein baustein für
eine europäische lösung für point of
sale und online zahlungen seien
szenario 2 die rolle von bargeld als
zahlungsmittel nimmt deutlich ab die
europäischen bürger innen hätten somit
schwierigkeiten auf das einzige
zahlungsmittel zuzugreifen das vom
öffentlichen sektor bereitgestellt wird
extreme ereignisse wie corvette 19
können die veränderungen der
zahlungsgewohnheiten beschleunigen durch
steigende wartungskosten der bargeld
infrastruktur könnte der rückgang der
verfügbarkeit und akzeptanz von bargeld
zusätzlich vorangetrieben werden ein
ähnlicher trend wird sich wahrscheinlich
aus der rasanten entwicklung des
elektronischen handels ergeben
szenario 3 eine andere geld form als
euro dominiertes zentralbankgeld oder
elektronisches geld wird zu einer
glaubwürdigen alternative zur
wertaufbewahrung mitteln in der eurozone
private akteure wie bitcoin oder die
brahm welche außerhalb der aufsicht der
europäischen finanzbehörden stehen oder
auch bit tech unternehmen die nicht euro
dominiert sind welche eine globale
verbreitung erreichen und für große
zahlungen im euro raum genutzt werden
könnten die geldpolitik im euroraum
schwächen ihr einfluss hätte auch
unklare auswirkungen auf die
grenzüberschreitende kapital mobilität
was letztlich die finanzstabilität
beeinträchtigen könnte unter diesen
umständen könnte die ausgabe eines
digitalen euros die europäische
souveränität und stabilität unterstützen
szenario 4 die eu beschließt
verbesserungen der gesamtkosten und des
ökologischen fußabdrucks seiner geld und
zahlungssysteme pro aktiv zu
unterstützen die herstellung von
zahlungs instrumenten und deren
infrastrukturen ist nicht immer
energieeffizient ein gut konzipiert hat
digitaler euro kann daher dazu beitragen
die gesamtkosten und den ökologischen
fußabdruck der zahlungssysteme im
euroraum zu verringern in diesem
zusammenhang würde das eurosystem eine
katalysator rolle spielen und mit gutem
beispiel vorangehen indem es anreize
schafft und druck auf die anbieter von
zahlungsdienstleistungen ausübt
aus diesen vier szenarien lassen sich
folgende anforderungen ableiten der
digitale euro sollte so gestaltet sein
dass etwaige negative auswirkungen auf
die geldpolitik und finanzstabilität
abgeschwächt werden die übermäßige
nutzung des digitalen euros als
anlageform und des damit verbundenen
risikos große umschichtungen sollten
vermieden werden der digitale euro
sollte im vergleich zu alternativen ein
effizienter weg seien die ökonomischen
und ökologischen ziele der eurozone zu
erreichen
[Musik]
aber bei all den visionen und ideen
sehen wir nicht in der technischen
umsetzung die größte herausforderung wie
kann für den endverbraucher den
lieferanten oder den unternehmer
sichergestellt werden dass ein digitaler
euro jederzeit verfügbar ist und überall
akzeptiert wird
und welche rolle spielt dabei der faktor
zeit
china testet bereits seine staatliche
digital währung namens juanes kommen
bereits apps zum einsatz mit denen
zahlungen innig johann realisiert werden
können sogar staatliche leistungen
werden zum teil in der neuen digital
währung ausgezahlt
mit dem digitalen reagiert china auf
crypto währungen wie bitcoin
dabei setzt tinas digital währung nur
teilweise auf einem block chain es
kommen auch traditionelle verrechnungs
methoden zum einsatz auch facebooks
lepra oder jetzt die m sollte nutzer
innen auf plattformen wie whatsapp oder
instagram die möglichkeit geben die
digitale währung beim online shopping zu
nutzen facebook stieß allerdings
weltweit in der politik und bei den
notenbanken auf widerstand viele sahen
in dem projekt einen angriff des
privatunternehmens auf das staatliche
wettmonopol und kündigten eine starke
regulierung von privaten digital
währungen an ryan brooks der ceo von
bayerns befürchtet dass wir ohne
regulierung in unserer geldpolitik keine
digitalen währungen erfolgreich
realisieren können
nun nach meiner persönlichen ansicht ist
hier in erster linie der nutzen zu
betrachten darüber sollten wir sprechen
bitte bedenken sie daß jede crypto
währung eine andere funktion
repräsentiert das sind alles
verschiedene netzwerke die für
unterschiedliche dinge entworfen werden
wenn wir also über bitcoin sprechen ist
er im grunde ein investment asset also
eine art digitales gold und wenn bitkom
reguliert werden sollte sollte es ebenso
wie investitionsgüter reguliert werden
es ist natürlich kein wertpapier aber es
ist etwas das die leute wegen seiner
werte haltungs eigenschaften kaufen und
halten im gegensatz zu operieren das ist
ein netzwerk der zahlungsverkehr oder
für crowdsourcing von finanzierungen
wenn es sich also um einen zahlungsplan
ismus handelt würden sie erwarten dass
die bankenaufsichtsbehörden darüber
sprechen das war meine tätigkeit bei der
ostsee es sollte also genau nach
nutzungs klassen reguliert werden jetzt
auch nach asset kategorien reguliert
wird und wenn es sich um einen
zahlungsplan ismus handel sollte er wie
ein zahlungsmittel es muss reguliert
werden ich denke das ist hier der
richtige denkansatz
facebook hat sein konzept einer
digitalen währung stark abgewandelt um
die volatilität seines kurses gering zu
halten soll es zunächst nur einen
sogenannten stable geben der jeweils
einen us-dollar abbild und dessen preis
dynamisch bzw automatisch gesteuert
werden kann auch den namen hat facebook
geändert der lepra heißt nun die im
dollar ein zulassungsantrag für die
europäische union ist allerdings noch
nicht eingegangen
warum also zögert die eu so mit der
einführung einer digitalen währung
christine lagarde meint es geht nur im
zusammenspiel von markt und regulatoren
[Musik]
wir müssen uns mit fragen des
datenschutzes befassen und mit vielen
fragen die in gewisser weise über den
bereich der zentralbanken hinausgehen
das heißt wir sind gezwungen mit anderen
behörden zusammenzuarbeiten zum beispiel
den finanzministerien und den
parlamenten der europäischen kommission
denn wenn der zeitpunkt kommt wird es
das leben vieler menschen auf eine sehr
intime weise ändern wir hören den
europäerinnen zu und wissen was ihnen
wichtig ist sie wollen dass ihre
privatsphäre geschützt ist aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir auch
sicherstellen dass es nicht zu einer
ausweitung von geldwäsche oder
terrorfinanzierung führt wir müssen also
bei jedem einzelnen aspekt die richtige
balance finden das wird noch ein paar
jahre dauern und wenn diese arbeit
abgeschlossen ist wird der regierungsrat
entscheiden ob er uns hierfür grünes
licht gibt oder wie die ganze sache
stoppen ich vermute dass wir für die
nächsten zwei jahre viel unterstützung
vom ezb-rat erwarten können und
hoffentlich das volle budget
bereitgestellt wird denn das ganze
funktioniert nicht ohne kosten zu
verursachen aber in zwei jahren wird
sich dann entscheiden ob es ein let's go
ist und wir einen digitalen euro
bekommen oder nicht nun mit blick auf
die märkte haben wir rational versucht
sie zu verstehen oder ihre gedanken zu
verstehen und was ihre erwartungen sind
klar ich als person spreche selbst nicht
mit den märkten und ich denke das ist
auch nicht mein aufgabengebiet es ist
sogar meine pflicht mich da raus zu
halten aber wir haben natürlich leute
die den markt beobachten und ihn kennen
ich meine man kann kein großer ein
käufer seien ohne tatsächlich eine
gewisse nähe dazu zu haben wie märkte
funktionieren und wie sie ticken vor
allem die erwartungen sind von
entscheidender bedeutung
sie führen also markt umfragen durch an
denen die unternehmen teilnehmen und die
wir genau auswerten
das ist aber nicht die einzige
komponente wir schauen auf alle
möglichen indikatoren und umfragen
wir sind fest entschlossen und
vollständig auf unser ziel fixiert die
preisstabilität zu erhalten die wir den
europäern und europäerin liefern müssen
das ist für uns das wichtigste aber die
märkte spielen natürlich auch eine rolle
und wir müssen auf sie achten und
überlegen wie sie die dinge sehen aber
unser ziel ist natürlich preisstabilität
die finanzminister der größten
euro-staaten unter anderem deutschland
frankreich spanien und italien haben
sich gegen einen digitalen schnellschuss
ausgesprochen eine digitale währung
dürfte nicht eingeführt werden bevor
nicht alle damit verbundenen risiken
auch in der gesetzgebung angemessen
berücksichtigt worden sind darüber
hinaus birgt die einschränkung der
verwendung eines digitalen euros die
gefahr dass die konvertierbarkeit zu
anderen formen des euros beeinträchtigt
wird zinsänderungen oder märkte auf
denen der digitale euro wie eine
parallelwährung behandelt wird stellen
eine bedrohung für die verwendung des
euros als zahlungsmittel in der
wirtschaft dar dass die einführung einer
digitalen währung durchaus positive
effekte auf die stabilität eines landes
haben kann zeigt sich am beispiel
venezuela das start-up value hilft den
menschen in venezuela im kampf gegen die
hyperinflation
ich heiße style menschen euro ich bin
mitbegründer und ceo von value unser
produkt hilft den venezolanern mit der
hyperinflation umzugehen und ihr geld
vor wertverlust zu schützen
überweisungen zu erhalten vor ort zu
bezahlen und um lebensmittel und
medikamente zu kaufen
sowohl unternehmen als auch verbraucher
sind in der lage waren und
dienstleistungen miteinander zu tauschen
und in crypto währung zu bezahlen unsere
vision ist es die wirtschaftliche
freiheit zu erhöhen
venezuela ist bekannt für seine
politische und wirtschaftliche
instabilität die hyperinflation hat dazu
geführt dass der boulevard in nur zwei
jahren 99 prozent seines wertes verloren
wohlhabende familien sahen ihr vermögen
schwinden und einkommensschwache
menschen wurden noch weiter in die
verzweiflung getrieben
sei man schon kennt diese geschichte nur
allzu gut
als ich in venezuela aufwuchs ging im
grunde alles was mein vater und meine
mutter in ihrem leben aufbauen konnten
verloren als die wirtschaft
zusammenbrach
wir hatten zum beispiel wasserknappheit
oder stromausfälle im ganzen land das
geld fingern hyperinflation er zu werden
das ist keine traurige geschichte die
ich hier versuche zu erzählen das ist
leider die realität der meisten
venezolaner mehr als 99 prozent der
venezolaner haben alles verloren was sie
aufgebaut haben weil das land
gescheitert ist alle ersparnisse aus der
mittelschicht die sich etwas aufbauen
wollte lösten sich in luft auf ich
wollte meine bestimmung finden und
wusste immer dass sich ein unternehmen
gründen und dinge entwickeln wollte
weshalb ich dann auch industrie design
studierte ich glaubte fest daran in der
lage zu sein dinge zu verändern
letztendlich habe ich diese karriere
nicht weiter verfolgt aber ich habe eine
menge dinge gelernt die mir die
technologie näher gebracht haben und so
bin ich beim thema crypto gelandet ich
habe mich dafür begeistert und als ich
dann das potenzial von crypto verstand
wurde mir klar dass venezuela der
perfekte ort ist um solche ideen in
großem maßstab umzusetzen
tatsächlich könnte eine dekonstruieren
der krypto währung der mittelschicht
helfen und diese hat die möglichkeit
unsere gesellschaft wie wir sie kennen
grundlegend zu verändern
das hauptproblem der venezolaner ist im
moment die hyperinflation und diese ist
nur das nebenprodukt einer totalen
misswirtschaft dieses landes
venezuelas abstieg in eine verarmte
diktatur hat der welt die verheerenden
auswirkungen der hyperinflation vor
augen geführt schleppende
grundversorgung extreme knappheit an
lebensmitteln und medizinischen mitteln
bürgerkriege gewalt venezolaner die ihre
währung aus venezuela in andere
stabilere währungen wie den us-dollar
transferieren konnten blieben verschont
ein luxus der meist nur für die ultra
elite in frage kam mittels crypto
währung möchte seinen mit seiner
plattform value allen die möglichkeit
geben sich gegen die hyperinflation zu
wehren
seiner meinung nach sind die instabilen
verhältnisse in seinem land der perfekte
nährboden für ein solches experiment
niemand traut mehr der währung oder der
regierung die menschen suchen nach
lösungen
an einem ort an dem die menschen
versuchen zu überleben ist die
hemmschwelle viel niedriger neue dinge
auszuprobieren sei es diese dollars
tisch münzen crypto währungen die leute
werden bereit sein mit wenig geld zu
starten und dann langsam versuchen es
irgendwie zu etablieren unser hauptziel
im moment als unternehmen ist es
händlern zu ermöglichen den dollar als
zahlungsmittel zu akzeptieren so dass
die leute immer weniger gezwungen sind
im bulli war zu benutzen wir
konzentrieren uns darauf ein produkt zu
entwickeln das von den reichen
gebildeten und technisch versierten bis
hin zu den menschen mit dem niedrigen
einkommen und geringen technischen
kenntnissen genutzt werden kann in einem
land wie venezuela wo der mindestlohn
bei ungefähr einem dollar liegt haben
sie die situation dass die meisten leute
ihr eigenes kleines geschäft eröffnen
hot dogs verkaufen oder lokales essen
wie arribas oder was auch immer aber sie
verkaufen es vorwiegend in ihren super
riesigen gemeinden also wollen wir den
gemeinden helfen zahlungen in dollar bzw
ito dollar also stable coins zu
akzeptieren und nutzer zu erreichen je
mehr verbraucher in dollar zahlen desto
besser für die händler je mehr händler
akzeptieren um so besser für die
verbraucher bis heute haben wir
millionen von dollar bewegt und haben
damit mehr als 150.000 haushalten
geholfen
30.000 aktive nutzer monatlich und wir
sehen dass es funktioniert in
wirklichkeit kein wirtschaftlicher
freiheit nur direkt durch innovation
erreicht werden was crypto währungen
sind
dabei darf man nicht vergessen dass
venezuela dies bereits versucht hat del
potro war der versuch einer krypta
währung zu etablieren die durch die
reichhaltigste ressource des landes
unterstützt wurde während pedro weithin
als durchschlagender misserfolg
betrachtet wurde sind sich viele
experten einig dass dieses experiment
ein notwendiger schritt war um eine
digitale währung für die zukunft zu
etablieren und heimen ist überzeugt dass
deren grundlage nämlich die blockzeiten
technologie nun stärker denn je benötigt
wird und sein land bereit ist für einen
weiteren versuch
die block 10 technologie ist tatsächlich
eine art paradigmenwechsel für die
menschheit eines der bedeutsamsten dinge
unserer zeit
man sieht langsam dass immer mehr
unternehmen damit beginnen ihre produkte
komplett auf einer blog chain aufzubauen
es ist fast so als würde sich eine
eigene wirtschaft entwickeln
wenn es einen weg ohne crypto gebe den
venezolanern ihre stabilität und
wirtschaftliche sowie finanzielle
freiheit zurückzugeben wäre das
natürlich ein viel besserer weg als mit
einem produkt erfolg zu haben das in
sich gar keinen wert besitzt
die hyperinflation venezuelas zeigt dass
die geldpolitik eines landes nicht immer
nach dem internationalen spielregeln
funktioniert
unsere erwartung die geldpolitik einer
zentralbank kann uns jederzeit retten
sollte unser geld in schieflage geraten
muss also in zukunft hinterfragt werden
wenn sogar ein erdöl reiches land wie
venezuela in eine hyperinflation geraten
kann einer der diese quantitativen
lockerungen in der geldpolitik schon
länger in frage stellt ist grau wie
männer
[Musik]
ich denke das ist falsch und ich denke
auch es ist falsch wenn zentralbanken
diese erwartung zu quantitativen
lockerungen nähren
die geldpolitik bildet die grundlage für
nachhaltiges nicht inflationäres
wirtschaftswachstum sie sorgt für
stabilität und zumindest auf mittlere
sicht für vorhersagbarkeit und auf
dieser basis kann man dann wirtschaften
kann aber es kann nicht sein dass jede
abschwächung jedes risiko oder jede
wirtschaftliche bedrohung die am
horizont auftaucht eine lockerung der
geldpolitik nach sich zieht ich denke
dass fiskalpolitik eine enorm wichtige
rolle spielt und wir das nicht
ausreichend berücksichtigen auch zum
teil weil der geldpolitik zu viel
gewicht beigemessen wird wir brauchen
hier ein besseres gleichgewicht zwischen
beiden das andere wäre auch unfair
gegenüber der zentralbanken gemeinschaft
und da sie gerade quantitative
lockerungen ansprechen singapur braucht
diese lockerungen nicht weil unsere
geldpolitik an unseren wechselkurs
gekoppelt ist sie unterliegen also nicht
der nullzinspolitik selbst wenn man über
negativzinsen und quantitative
lockerungen als ergänzung zu einer
wechselkurs zentrierten geldpolitik
nachdenkt diese überlegungen treffen für
uns nicht zu wir können wenn nötig den
wechselkurs pfad wieder auf null
absenken bitte verstehen sie mich nicht
falsch wir haben noch nie absichtlich
eine politik der währungsabwertung
betrieben aber wir können dem
wechselkurs jederzeit wieder nach unten
korrigieren was wir in der vergangenheit
auch schon getan haben wenn wir der
meinung sind dass der aktuelle
wechselkurs zu eng ist können wir in
jeder zeit nach unten re zentrieren und
mit dieser flexibilität gibt es
eigentlich keine einschränkung wir haben
also einen ziemlich großen
geldpolitischen spielraum ohne dass wir
über quantitative lockerung nachdenken
müssen
[Musik]
während die ezb also derzeit noch an
einem konzept zum digitalen euro
arbeitet sind zentralbanken anderer
staaten meist schon einen schritt weiter
2018 gab auch das oberste banken
institut der bundesrepublik deutschland
die deutsche bundesbank bekannt aktiv an
einer blog jane basierten lösung zu
arbeiten
das institut mit hauptsitz in frankfurt
am main verwaltet rund 200 milliarden
euro an staatlichen reserven und es teil
des europäischen systems der
zentralbanken nach eigenen angaben
intensiviert die banken nun seine
forschung im bereich der distributor
technology und hat bereits einen
entsprechenden partner genannt ocean
protokoll soll zukünftig mit seiner
technologie die deutsche bundesbank in
ihrem vorhaben unterstützen das 2017 in
singapur gegründete unternehmen
entwickelt innovative apps für die
kommende daten ökonomie und verbindet
daten anbieter und nutzer mit hilfe der
block chain technologie ocean ermöglicht
es daten eigentümern daten zu
monetarisieren und gleichzeitig die
kontrolle über ihre datenbestände zu
behalten
die deutsche bundesbank ruft also ein
eigenes blog chain project ins leben der
fokus dieser zusammenarbeit liegt
hierbei auf einem dezentralen netzwerk
das nutzern einen permanent
symmetrischen zugriff auf daten
gestattet dadurch sollen beispielsweise
echtzeit aktualisierungen von
statistiken unter wahrung der
datenhoheit möglich sein von der
bundesbank hieß es im protokoll war als
einziges unternehmen in der lage eine
technische lösung für unser vorhaben
anzubieten die bereits funktionsfähig
ist
außerdem soll eine plattform für die
sichere verwahrung übertragung und
nutzung öffentlicher und privater daten
entwickelt werden offen bleibt ob das
unternehmen aus singapur auch bei der
forschung an einem digitalen euro
beteiligt ist
doch wie sieht es mit den deutschen
unternehmen aus wir denken diese im
allgemeinen über die einführung und
nutzbarkeit eines digitalen euros
78 prozent bei so drei viertel aller
unternehmen ab 50 beschäftigten sind für
die einführung eines digitalen euro
nur jedes fünfte unternehmen 20 prozent
hält diese pläne für wenig
erfolgversprechend
das ist das ergebnis einer jüngsten
umfrage unter 600 52 unternehmen aller
branchen in deutschland aus dem jahr
vor allem die möglichkeit das sonst
andere privat eher digital währungen zum
einsatz kommen die europäische werte
untergraben könnten spricht aus sicht
der unternehmen für einen digitalen euro
69 prozent der unternehmen sehen es als
notwendig an mit lokalisierten
wertpapieren nahtlose zahlungs und
abwicklungsprozesse auf dem kapitalmarkt
zu ermöglichen fast genauso viele
nämlich 64 prozent denken dass es von
vorteil ist einen digitalen euro zu
haben sollte die bedeutung von bargeld
abnehmen so hätten bürger im digitalen
zeitalter weiterhin direkten zugang zur
zentralbank dass ein digitaler euro ist
der ezb in krisenzeiten ermöglicht
innovative geldpolitische instrumente
effektiver umzusetzen glauben 60 prozent
der befragten
rund 40 prozent würden gern
zahlungsprozesse zunehmend
automatisieren und sehen hier den bedarf
für einen programmierbaren euro in der
industrie stichwort mtm payment also
machine to machine zahlungen im internet
nur 11 prozent sind der meinung ein
digitaler euro hätte überhaupt keine
vorteile
[Musik]
neben den verfechtern des digitalen
zeitalters gibt es allerdings auch
skeptiker und um die einführung eines
digitalen eur
65 prozent also etwa zwei drittel sehen
hier datenschutzrisiken sollte die
zentralbank tiefere einblicke in unsere
zahlungsprozess erhalten auch sieht
ungefähr jedes zweite unternehmen
dadurch die finanzstabilität gefährdet
denn durch die ausgabe des digitalen
euros könnte der einfluss der banken in
krisenzeiten sinken doch nur drei
prozent der banken und
finanzdienstleister halten nichts von
der ausgabe eines digitalen euros durch
die ezb
ca 8 prozent der gesamtwirtschaft meint
die wirtschaft müsste eigene lösungen
für den digitalen zahlungsverkehr der
zukunft entwickeln 13 prozent geben an
es spreche nichts gegen einen digitalen
euro
[Musik]
so sprechen sich 35% des banken- und
finanzgeschäftsführer die einführung
eines digitalen euros aus
in der bewertung zur tendenz würden
46er einem digitalen euro zustimmen und
nur 9 prozent sagen klar nein
[Musik]
die ezb ist jedenfalls fest entschlossen
einen digitalen euro einzuführen den so
genannten euro
dieser soll parallel zum bargeld
ausgegeben werden das ausdrücklich nicht
abgeschafft werden soll
damit reagiert die ezb auf zahlreiche
neue formen des bezahlens wie zum
beispiel crypto assets wie etwa bitcoin
dm oder chinas yuan
die zb präsidentin magath geht davon aus
dass der euro schon in vier jahren in
den virtuellen geldbörsen der
verbraucher innen der eurozone liegen
wird und dann auch kräftig zum einsatz
kommt china ist bei der entwicklung
einer digitalen währung weit voraus und
auch schwedens zentralbank arbeitet an
der digitalen krone wie der euro am ende
genau aussieht wissen auch die
währungshüter noch nicht aber so viel
ist bereits klar der digitale euro wird
wie bargeld von der ezb ausgegeben und
kontrolliert es entsteht also wie münzen
scheine oder buchgeld das auf dem
girokonto oder sparbuch liegt durch die
geldschöpfung der ezb und der
geschäftsbanken im unterschied zum
bitcoin und anderem crypto assets behält
also die notenbank die kontrolle über
die währung womit stabilität und
sicherheit des digitalen euros
garantiert werden soll
der euro soll in einer art virtuellen
geldbörse aufbewahrt werden und mittels
eines einfachen verfahrens zum beispiel
durch eine app oder einen qr code in die
virtuelle kasse des verkäufers wandern
dies wird online zum beispiel via
internet als auch offline über bluetooth
möglich sein eine zahlung soll in
zukunft also viel einfacher und auch
viel schneller möglich sein als bisher
über sepa überweisung
funktionieren soll das ganze über ein
separates konto sozusagen einem direkt
konto bei der ezb dennoch verwaltet
durch die geschäftsbanken so ist der
euro selbst dann nur noch durch die ezb
geschützt wenn private finanzinstitute
durch eine krise in schieflage geraten
auch der schutz der privatsphäre es
zunehmend gesichert da im unterschied zu
großen amerikanischen
kreditkartenunternehmen bei der
transaktion keine persönlichen daten
übermittelt werden
am 14 juli hat der rat der europäischen
zentralbank beschlossen das projekt
digitaler euro einzuläuten
es wurden eine menge analysen
vorgenommen feedback von bürger innen
sowie aus fachkreisen eingeholt und eine
praktische erprobung durchgeführt
mit vermutenden ergebnissen all dies hat
den startschuss für das projekt
digitaler euro ermöglicht und wer weiß
vielleicht werden wir in vier jahren mit
dem digitalen euro genauso
selbstverständlich einkaufen die bisher
mit kredit oder debitkarte
die ezb und der euroraum sind auf einem
guten weg unser finanzsystem
kontrolliert und sicher in das digitale
zeitalter zu führen
der digitale euro wird ein nächster
großer schritt in die zukunft für europa
und seine bürger im ins heim
[Musik]